[Music]
hello
welcome everyone we are so glad you are
joining us today
welcome welcome to our panel on
pursuing the mba from a non-traditional
background
what we'd like to do today is talk about
you and your potential journey to the
nba
and possibly the mba here at stanford's
graduate school of business
and so i'm going to ground us in just a
quick introduction
to the program here and then we're
really going to turn things over to our
panel of current students and alumni
i'll kick us off with a couple of
questions but really we will be relying
on you today
to drive the conversation we want to
answer your questions
uh especially for those of you thinking
about making a pivot in your career
or maybe accelerating your career and
are trying to identify
if an mba is going to help you get there
so we are going to do our best to get to
all of that today
and we'll try to do that all in just
about an hour
all right so as i said this
this day and this time that we're
spending together is really all about
you and how we can help you get to where
you want to go next
and so when we think about you and the
and the backgrounds and perspectives of
all of the students who join us at
stanford
it's important to remember that every
single individual who's joining us in
the community at the gsb
is bringing a unique perspective uh and
experiences
and that comes from your academic
background as well as your professional
background
so we threw up just a couple of stats
here so you can get a quick snapshot of
one of our more recent class profiles
these numbers change every year but as
you can see there's over 100 different
undergraduate institutions and almost
300
different organizations that our
students have been a part of
before they start at the gsb so when you
think about a class of a little over 400
students
those are a lot of really unique
individual voices and perspectives that
are in the classroom
and there are so many different journeys
that happened before
the gsb and we're wondering what yours
are going to be what could your journey
to the gsb
look like and so with that in mind we'd
like to do
a little walk through the journeys of
these four individuals who so generously
joined us today
so we're going to kick things off with a
quick introduction
of our panel they're going to share
their names where they
join the gsb from and a little bit about
their pre-gsb
employment and professional experiences
and then we're going to jump into some
questions about how they made the
decision
to come to business school and whether
or not that was
worthwhile for them so with that uh
khalil i think we'll start with you
great thank you so much um good
afternoon good evening good morning
wherever you may be in the world i'm
khalil
um class of 2020 at the gsb um
i've been an entrepreneur my whole life
started selling snickers when i was in
middle
school and sneakers and i was in high
school and it's only snowballed from
there
um and then after a couple of my best
friends dropped out of high school
uh because they felt really far behind
in math i started tutoring kids in math
and my freshman year in undergrad i
ended up founding a non-profit
called learn fresh and we partnered with
the nba and made a fun math game for
elementary and middle school students
that's kind of centered around
basketball and the statistics around
basketball
and so i ran that organization for seven
years
and then was kind of plateauing in my
personal learning at the same time
while the organization was finally
sustainable and so that's what kind of
prompted me to come back to business
school
um and yeah really excited to be with
you here today
thank you that's awesome
so i'm demo i'm calling in from beirut
which is where i'm from so it's 2 a.m
here
kind of a testament to how much i care
about this community and giving back
and before school i worked at the united
nations development program
here in beirut mainly working with
women and youth and to help them
help them get jobs and advance in their
in their careers and i was working
mainly with the private sector so all
the funding was coming from
private companies and i thought at that
time
all the actual decision making is coming
from where this funding is
so i wanted to join that side of the
table uh work on social impact from the
private sector side
and i thought the mba would be a perfect
thing to do
at that time and i i stand by
my decision right now i'm working
on a startup in the uh professional
coaching space so i'm working on a
career um career companion platform to
help millennials
find more meaningful careers and i can
talk more about how i transitioned from
the united nations to that in a bit
thank you so much
hi my name is yvonne mba 2019
i come from
the social sector uh i did community
organizing
right out of college in a neighborhood
in brooklyn that had the highest
um it had the highest
rate of violence in in new york at the
time
um and crime and a lot of it was due to
the unemployment rate after
the 2008 crisis financial crisis and so
i learned that
oh man i have a lot of leadership skills
i need to gain in this work and work
with people
and so right after that i went into
teaching i did teach for america for two
years
um learned a lot of social emotional
skills from working with
36 different personalities in the
classroom and all different types
of teachers and instruction
instructional leaders
after teach for america i wanted to work
at the
um at an even higher level to scale my
impact and so i worked as
a school administrator director of data
for three charter schools in brooklyn
and after that transition to to the mba
to
because i was wondering what the private
sector is all about
great thank you for sharing your journey
mackenzie
hi everybody uh so my name is mackenzie
and
i am the only current student here on
the panel so excited to answer any
questions
uh because i am in the thick of it um so
i
uh grew up in the seattle area this is
definitely a west coast girl
um i went to washington university in st
louis for undergrad
and kind of knew i wanted to be in the
nonprofit social sector and so right
after school
i went and i got a fulbright fellowship
and i went to indonesia
where i was teaching english there and i
ended up doing that for two years
uh loved it it was an amazing experience
um
and then kind of came back and was like
okay now what
so i first started working i did like a
year and a half at a small
kind of boutique consulting firm doing
market research
uh which was cool but it just wasn't
like my passion i wasn't
that excited about it so i've switched
and
started working for path which is a
large global health nonprofit in seattle
um and i was in a variety of roles there
but was mostly focused on the
strategic partnerships and philanthropy
so i was doing a lot of fundraising and
most of my time was spent kind of on the
operations side so managing all the
donor database and um the
forecasting and revenue and kind of
looking at all the operation side and so
um at some point i kind of was figuring
i'd go to
go back to school for something and was
uh looking at both an
uh mpa a master's in public
administration and an mba
um and ultimately realized that for me
i think i looked at the course listings
for both and the mpa
i realized that like i already knew all
the things like i already had so much
experience with everything i would learn
in an mpa program but the mba program
was that was actually what i wanted to
learn and so
um that's kind of how i shifted to get
uh look
at the mba program and i've loved it and
so i'm i'm here i've
just finished my first year um last week
and i just started my
summer internship yesterday so um
definitely
lots to talk about awesome well thank
you so much for being here especially
when work has just begun
i am going to stop sharing my screen now
so we can really focus on just being
together and being present
uh many of you kind of already hinted at
answers to the first question i had for
all of you
and i think mackenzie really did a
pretty detailed job of explaining you
know when you're thinking about the mba
but you were also considering other
degrees
so certainly coming from a pathway or an
a background professionally that
wouldn't necessarily kind of scream
obvious answer mbas is in my future i'm
wondering if maybe one or two of you
could also share a little bit more
about that decision-making process for
you deciding that an mba
was the right degree as opposed to some
other graduate program or maybe just
continuing to work in a different way
so thank you mckenzie for sharing your
perspective perspective i'm wondering if
one of two of you want to elaborate a
little bit on kind of your journey to
getting to the
yes an mba is right for me decision
i can go ahead and answer that
for me the other option was going into
international development or economics
and i really thought that this would be
a path for me i was in love with
development and love with
helping um affordable communities around
lebanon
but i realized especially after
researching the gsb
in particular that i would get an
education that's
about me as a whole human and it was
developed me and my leadership skills as
a whole human
and not only the quant skills or the
financial skills or
everything that is typically thought of
as an mba and this is
what i came to understand while talking
to people who went to the gsb i didn't
know that before my assumption was that
okay you go and you go into something
that banking or consulting or things
like that and i learned that
i can get the skills that i want as a as
a person
to do an mba rather than having this
very particular focus on international
development so that's my
thought process on it great
thank you uh khalil yvonne anything to
add there if your journey was a little
bit different
getting to that conclusion sure yeah i
um i guess for me i so i started my
first real company
freshman year in undergrad um and i knew
nothing about the world and nothing
about entrepreneurship and nothing about
leadership and
made all the mistakes that a first-time
founder would make um
and then as i started to go down deeper
down that path
when most you know a lot of my friends
from undergrad were going into
consulting or banking
and kind of building those core business
skill sets
um when i was still kind of trying to
like fumbling through learning how to
like fly the plane while while building
it um
after a certain point in time i re i
felt as though
i was just kind of hitting a plateau in
terms of what i could learn
fully on my own right and i'm kind of
you know i i would read a lot and i try
to
gain as many mentors as possible to
learn directly from them but i
really started to yearn for um like a
laboratory-like environment where i
could truly just work on myself
and not always have to and almost have
the consequences be a little bit lower
for for a little bit so that i could
actually get better um because i was
realizing
some of the real world consequences to
not being a great leader not being a
great manager um
and so that's what kind of sparked the
the journey to start thinking about grad
school in general
um i was actually considering phd
programs
um in education the stanford in
particular has a really awesome learning
sciences and technology design program
that's kind of at the intersection of
education and cs and all kinds of really
interesting things
and so for me it was between an mba and
that that phd program and i realized
that the leadership specific kind of
skills i wouldn't necessarily get in
that phd setting
um and then the deeper that i got into
the masters in ed mba it kind of seemed
like the perfect marriage of both for me
um and so that's what led me to apply
fantastic thank you well now seems like
a great time to dive
into some of the questions we're seeing
from the group today and
siobhan has our first question and
they're wondering
looking back what was one of the biggest
misconceptions you had
upon entering the gsb so whether that
was about
misconceptions about mbas in general or
maybe about the stanford business school
was there any kind of idea or concept
that you thought or were expecting from
the experience
that either that didn't really play out
the way you thought it might
so kind of open to whoever can think of
anything
i can start um i would say in this it's
built off the previous points but
um i was expecting it to be like much
more quantitative much
more like hard business skills
um and have been very pleasantly
surprised at like the soft skills and
the leadership
opportunities and the leadership
development um
and those opportunities i think that's
been um
probably the biggest kind of
misconception that i had going in
and have loved all the opportunities
i've had
i would say that my misconception going
in was
that it would a lot of the community the
courses
the clubs would be focused around
entrepreneurship
and i realized that there are a lot of
courses clubs and
members in the community who can and
that can
fire you into and charge you off and
ready you for the traditional areas in
the
in the private world and they they can
be so supportive
and it feels awesome to be in the
more traditional part of the private
world and feels
uh supported by the alumni community
while here
excellent well uh khalil do you have
anything to add there
i was just gonna say an interesting
almost corollary to that was that i
i was worried that i was gonna be just a
complete loner at the gsb that no one
else was going to come from this
i didn't even have the language to talk
to to classify it as a non-traditional
background
but i thought i'd be you know maybe one
of five um
and it turns out there's a lot of us and
so i very quickly
you know found my tribe and also built
really amazing relationships through all
kinds of gsb experiences
whether it's gsts or different classes
with people that i wouldn't necessarily
have met in any other kind of walks of
life but
um i was worried i wouldn't be able to
find that group and i did very quickly
thank you so much for sharing that
particular perspective because that
actually leads us into a question that
we had from keith
so keith is recognizing that for a lot
of people that might be coming from the
nonprofit space or education space
you may not necessarily have had the
same quant exposure either in your
academic background or in your previous
work experience
before starting the mba so as you're
thinking about your application
one he's wondering if you know what
indicators or did you do anything
in terms of how you highlighted what
kind of quant readiness you might have
did you do that in the application
or did you take any time to do any sort
of preparatory work
yourself personally before starting the
program
especially if you felt like cleo you
were saying like i'm not sure i'm gonna
necessarily be in the same place where
everyone else is at the point of arrival
so maybe folks can focus a little bit on
that quant side because it sounds like
that might be on on people's minds right
now
i can answer that i think for me
i i wasn't i didn't do any preparatory
work
or think about this a lot before i just
thought i'll
just dive deep and try to figure it out
and what surprised me is
how supportive the community was i felt
like khalil i'm like i don't know what
i'm doing here it's going to be very
hard um i only work on
projects on the ground i don't know how
to do this but every time i needed
help and anything quantum related in all
the like first few
classes accounting and um other
very excel heavy classes you always have
people who are very supportive so
it kind of reassured me in the first
three four weeks that it's gonna be okay
even if i
didn't have such a strong clump
background
two things i did was i uh
when i decided to work as a school
administrator i wanted to work in a
functional
role that would allow me to boost my
analytical skills so i did a lot of
excel in coding um
in in that position that's one thing the
second thing is i
took online courses in economics
accounting and finance
that helped
great thank you both so both pov
and story have some questions related to
the career support
and i love any opportunity to highlight
the amazing work that our career
management center
does with our students so they are
wondering and i'll try to
capture both of their questions they're
wondering if uh any of you can share
some more about the gsb's career support
system uh and particularly whether it's
for um
and this may vary for each of you so
support that they can help um for anyone
interested in education
or in nonprofit or for those that are
actually interested in
pivoting into sort of the private sector
so i know yvonne and mackenzie you have
a little more experience where you're
actually
maybe transitioning out of that space
into something very different so
maybe a couple of you can share a little
bit about your personal experiences with
uh the career support that you've gotten
at the gsb
uh yeah uh so quickly i
the cr i'm sure there's a chart that
they could probably find and send in the
chat in like five seconds because
um they're like magical people like that
but there's this chart that shows where
people actually found their jobs whether
it's
through on-campus recruiting through you
know direct like
direct relationships with their fellow
peers and gs beers
um and how how helpful the cmc was
i found the cmc really helpful
to almost just talk through what i
wanted not necessarily like the search
itself
i didn't get connected to my current
employer through the cmc
but the cmc help in like a lot of
one-on-one sessions helped me kind of
just disentangle like all the different
things that were going on in my in my
mind
and kind of create my personal criteria
um but i mean you'll hear a thousand
times how amazing the network is
and as many times as you hear it it's
still undersold how incredible the
network is
um and so that i actually ended up
finding my current role where i'm a
co-founder of a new venture studio where
we're building startups from scratch and
funding them
i found that role through a connection
directly from a professor
um who i got really close to at the gsb
and so kind of something that might not
be on the pie chart but
another one for me
yeah i um and my experience has been a
little bit atypical i would say so
uh everything was virtual for us
especially in the fall as all that
um kind of recruiting was ramping up um
but i
found they did a bunch of uh virtual
uh like reflection sessions i think i
think that's kind of what you're
relating to well and
i loved those i found them really
helpful i would say you had to like
kind of see that they were happening and
like make sure you like made it happen i
know a lot of people who didn't go and
then like in the spring they like heard
that these sessions had happened and
they were great
oh i missed that and so kind of staying
on top of those opportunities is
important
i'm really glad i went to those and i
felt like going into the recruiting
season i had
a really clear idea of what i wanted and
then it was just about
finding and matching to that opportunity
and so um
i met with a career advisor a couple
times um i think again in a virtual
world it wasn't just like i could drop
into somebody's office and i wouldn't
say develop like a close relationship
with anybody
yet um but i would say they were really
helpful and kind of you know when i
needed to chat with somebody and bounce
some ideas off them that was really
useful
and then the i would just say like the
career
page and just like all the the job board
i guess um that was extremely useful to
me
um and i just set up like a little alert
and so anytime
with like keywords for what i was
interested in um and i'd get emails
every morning
and then i think i started my internship
search in like february so i didn't like
everybody else was doing it like all
winter and i
did not because i was more interested in
the startup space so my
search was a little bit later um and
then once i was like
actually kind of in that mode then then
i did meet with the career advisor again
and kind of got a little bit more help
and
you know direction and then was able to
land a great role for the summer so
i've found their like especially their
reflection sessions very useful
thanks mackenzie uh yvonne i'd love to
hear from you
because you shared that you came from an
education background and i know you're
doing something a little different these
days
so can you share a little bit about what
that transition was like for you
yeah of course um so i work at jpmorgan
now and i just finished a rotational
program and placed full-time into the
company
um doing strategy and analytics work
um that is not the kind of work i did
before
business school and so it was the skills
i
focused on a lot while at business
school
cmc helped me figure out
where in in the private world i would
like to go to
tech vc banking the options seemed so
many and i felt overwhelmed
um but they helped me take it slow
figure out okay of these these the
skills that they they're looking for
these are the type of
interests that you may need to have um
and they just helped me think about it
in a really structured and clear manner
and i felt incredibly cared for
throughout the process because
they followed up with me consistently
throughout my time at the gsb
and when someone follows up with you as
much as they did
you know that they i felt really
sincerely cared for and that's my
favorite feeling from working at the
working with cmc to help me find a job
thank you so much for sharing that story
like i said i love any opportunity
to talk about the work that that group
does i think the advisors
uh are just so generous with their time
and they do they they stay in touch they
follow up and they do genuinely
care and want to help everyone find what
it is that they they want to do next
uh some people come in with a really
clear idea and for others it really is a
time of exploration for you
at business school and that exploration
is encouraged
and then guided and supported by by
people like the cmc advisors on campus
all right thank you for talking about
careers for a minute we're going to
switch gears and talk about
academics uh so story is interested
in whether or not anyone pursued a joint
or dual degree
or if you took any other classes
elsewhere on the stanford campus so
khalil you are our resident joint degree
student so i'll have you speak about
that
uh and then i'm wondering if any of the
rest of you could share maybe any of the
other across the street classes you have
taken or maybe planned to take
in the next year
great uh yeah so as i've already stated
i did a
masters in ed along with my mba um the
way that joint program works
is you can actually complete both in two
years
or you can extend it for an additional
quarter um i opted to extend it for an
additional quarter and i'm really glad i
did it kind of gave me a little bit more
breathing room
and i felt like i didn't have to either
take a ton of classes
every quarter um or leave without taking
some of the classes that i
that i really wanted to specifically at
the at the ed school because the first
year
is more more mba focused um i did my
undergraduate degree
in education um education and social
entrepreneurship and so i came in with a
fairly
strong both academic and real world
background in education
and so that allowed me to i think kind
of not necessarily
explicitly like skip cl mandatory
classes to go to some of the advanced
ones but when i was able to
um just open it up to more elective
based education classes
um the gse is phenomenal and i actually
think one of the
kind of like an under the radar gem at
stanford um
the you know it's an education school
and so the professors are amazing and
have
tremendous pedagogy and really care
about their students
uh and so yeah i i love that joint
experience i also just really
practically some people may dislike this
but i actually really liked finishing
in a kind of like off cycle in december
um because it felt like
i was just able to when the madness of
like of graduation was upon us and
everyone felt like they were leaving
i kind of was able to take solace that i
didn't have wasn't able to
didn't have to get kicked out of the gsp
or get kicked out of stanford and i can
kind of
stay around for a little bit longer um
yeah happy to answer any more specifics
about the
m.a mba program but that's kind of the
overview um
i really enjoyed it i would if there's
one piece of feedback on the on the
joint program um
i think that yeah there's there's some
interesting things about there it was
i had a pretty small cohort like we had
12 or 13.
um and so i'm always beating the drum of
trying to get more people to do those
joint degrees because i think they're
just wonderful experiences
and in an interdisciplinary world that
we live in i think you can really draw
upon
both of those things in in great ways
and so i want more people to do that
great thanks for that plug i'll throw in
a quick fun fact
uh for the audience that approximately
one in five
of our mbas are pursuing a joint or dual
degree of some kind
uh but i think the numbers are sort of
off the charts when it comes to people
who are just
dabbling and exploring different
interests across campus
uh where something is like almost
everyone um like 80
uh or higher will take at least one
class somewhere else at some point
during their mba experience
uh for so for the rest of the panel does
anyone want to share
maybe a class that they took elsewhere
on stanford's campus and what led you to
that decision
no you should go i took a class at the
design school so
design thinking and i
loved it because when you're at the gsb
you're sort of surrounded by gs viewers
all the time you're in the gsb mindset
you live across your classes you don't
explore the rest of campus
so even like walking these 10 minutes
from the dsb
campus to the design school was really
helpful in exploring but the class
itself
i thought was fascinating because we
worked in group
projects and every person in the group
was from a different school
so that was very helpful for me to see
like how others are thinking
how if i want to like build a startup
which is
in that mindset how i can bring on
different expertise different
types of people how diverse people into
my team just to be able to produce like
better results and have
a better team overall i think the the
professors especially at the design
schools
they get you way outside of your comfort
zone uh you do projects you put yourself
out there you do research on the field
like we went to mcdonald's for our
research like almost on a
daily basis which was kind of random but
um
it was very interesting to be in a very
diverse crowd
and the professors really did a great
job at
putting us out there and outside of our
comfort zone so i would highly
recommend that anything in the design
school honestly sounds awesome
one of the biggest things that drew me
to stanford is
the number of experiential courses that
it offers
at the gsb particularly and so if i was
going to use my few credits to
um because i also actually did a joint
degree with the harvard mpa program
so if i was going to use my few credits
to do across the street class i wanted
to be
even more experiential if possible and i
was thinking
what offers that and it happened to be
design thinking just like dima has
suggested and so i did the design
thinking summer institute i think it was
a week or two weeks before
um uh the gsb classes started
and it is it's still in my bones
how experiential that that course was
and the
design thinking principles are still
like tattooed into my
into my brain because um it was a
powerful experience so i definitely
recommend looking into that if
if you if you want to
awesome well speaking of powerful
experiences what a perfect segue
to get to say ellie's question and i'll
give folks a second to think about
this one but jump in as something comes
to mind
uh what do you think is the most
mind-shifting or new experience that you
have had
at the gsb so it sounds like that class
certainly was quite memorable and
continues to be informative to you
were there other either academic or or
social activities or something else that
happened maybe it was something that
happened during an internship
uh something that was really pivotal for
you
i'll be the first to talk about
touchy-feely i don't know if all four
are
um but you may have heard of this class
uh
colloquially called touchy-feely uh
technically called interpersonal
dynamics uh
people talk about it as like a
life-changing class and it truly was
that for me so the
the structure of the class is that
you're in a small group of about 12
people
and you meet for like six hours
once a week or maybe even longer that
like six or eight hours once a week
and just talk about your feelings and
the relationships that you're building
within that group um and you learn so
much i learned i learned
so much about myself about how i'm
perceived by others um
i cried like a dozen times i like
i unlocked all kinds of like memories
like it was almost like
therapeutic in a way um but i also went
through it and i did the readings with
my partner
um and that was a really powerful way to
kind of bring her
into the gsb experience a little bit and
build shared language that we now use on
a daily or weekly basis
in our relationship and so uh touchy
feely was definitely
mind-bending for me
mine would be that plus the arbuckle
leadership
fellows program which is a program that
you
start doing in your second year for the
fall and winter
quarters where you're basically taught
how to be a coach
and you become a coach for nine nba ones
and for me that was transformative one
because i now have a career in coaching
so it was at the basis of that i've
never heard of coaching before
it's not anything that i was exposed to
in lebanon or in the middle east
and when i saw how supportive my
coaching cohort was
and how how great the feedback was from
the people i was coaching
i thought that would be something that i
want to do
full-time because i see how much it has
impacted
people and it has impacted me and i
think it gives me
sort of the self um fulfillment of like
okay i'm empowering other people to be
their best selves
and i had never heard about this concept
before i learned it in my second year
and i applied to it because my friend
told me like two days before the
application does that it's like oh
there's this program
you should apply to it i'm like cool
sounds awesome never heard of it let me
just apply it this is like for me most
of my gsb experiences like someone is
telling me
uh two days before something that i
should submit an application
and it's very transformative it was very
transformative for me
uh to have that impact on other people
and to
to like khali said it's you discover
yourself
much in a much more holistic way
when you're being coached by executive
coaches who
usually cost like thousands of dollars
per month and you just get that
experience at the tsp
thank you so i know a lot of the
examples shared were from our electives
so mckenzie i know you haven't gotten to
dive into electives too much at this
point as a first-year student you're
you're grounded in a lot of those core
required classes
but you get to kind of pick and choose
here and there uh reflecting back on
your
first year academic experience uh were
there any kind of key takeaways either
from one of your core classes or one of
your other kind of academic
experiences or guest speakers or
something that you're kind of still
holding on to the way of on maybe it's
not tattooed but maybe it's still
something that
kind of pops up in your in your mind
from time to time
i've been uh racking my brain trying to
think about this um i
i think it's hard because i'm like still
like in the mix and so it's hard to kind
of really reflect
um actually one of my my like first
project for my internship they want me
to kind of reflect on my year and like
see what we
what kind of takeaways i've had from my
classes that i can apply to the startup
and things that i've learned so it's
actually something i can work on
tomorrow
um but um i took a class
uh called people operations from startup
to scale up
that i just like happened upon um in
winter quarter
and it was really like one of my first
electives that i was able to choose and
i
loved it i just like really fell in love
with
um the professor and like just we were
also taking all the core classes which
are
fine but like this one was just like so
much better in comparison and
i think this one was really cool because
of the guest speakers and almost every
class we had
um some high profile or not
uh usually a startup founder come and
speak um
and it was that's probably the thing
that i've realized um and has been
really cool for me at stanford is
just like the access you have and the
people you get to meet and the
fireside chats with like the founder of
this company and this and that like i
mean it's just wild the number of like
opportunities that you have
and i think that has been probably one
of the perks of the pandemic
the silver lining is i think those
opportunities have like
i guess is that they've just like
completely magnified and tripled
in the number because they don't fly
anybody in anymore
everything is on zoom and so it's so
easy to just get somebody to come for an
hour and just
zoom in and so we can talk to like
crazy big names ceo cfo ceos like all
these different people and so what i
loved in the
startup class was these people who were
in the middle of you know starting their
company or they were you know a few
years in and were able to really reflect
on that and i
think i took away a lot of learnings
from that which
as i'm looking into going into kind of a
i don't know series a startup maybe
um and that's what i'm looking at this
summer um there's so much learnings i
can take from that class and i'd say
that's the one that has like been the
most
useful in terms of content-wise that i'm
able to take into my internship
so that has been a great class great
thank you for sharing that perspective i
think it's important
for everyone to remember that most of
the conversations tend to gravitate
towards uh the electives that stick with
people after the second year but
so you know so much can also happen in
that first year as well as you're just
getting started
uh so yvonne brought this up earlier i'm
going to bring it back to the group now
we've had a few questions in the chat
and q a about experiential learning at
the gsb
specifically as it relates to
entrepreneurship and
social impact uh social innovation i'm
going to also kind of couple this with
some other questions we've been seeing
about the centers for
entrepreneurship and social innovation
so i'm wondering if we have anyone on
the panel today
who took advantage or you know
participated in any of the activities or
resources that
either of those centers organize and if
you did any of those experiential
kind of learning activities through the
centers during your time
at the program
all right i'll hop in while others think
um short answer is yes and yes
uh tons tons of resources an abundant
amount of resources
um and classes i actually you know
given so my background my undergraduate
degree is in social entrepreneurship and
education
i ran the i was you know i was a social
entrepreneur a non-profit went through
lots of different fellowships i queen
green things like that um and so i
actually
for my first six months on campus i
actually didn't participate in as much
of the social entrepreneurship related
things
um didn't like go to as many of the
meetups and all of that
uh and then i realized that i really
missed that
um kind of like hanging out at uh at the
kind of like the center for social
entrepreneurship and things like that
and so
i took much more advantage of it in my
second year um
let's see specific things that i did
there's a handful of classes that are
taught by amazing
both professors like full-time
professors and also lecturers that they
bring in for some really quick
short um short classes and they're still
practitioners and so they're
like a ton of real world lived
experience
um i participated in uh a
summer i got a fellowship for the summer
program
after my between my second year and my
kind of ending
autumn quarter to support me in working
with
a local non-profit this is kind of like
in the middle of the pandemic
i'd actually started a nonprofit
initiative called gift card bank
to distribute gift cards to low-income
families in need um and so i was working
with a local food bank
and got a fellowship to do that and so
stanford can kind of effectively pay you
to do social impact work over the summer
i was fortunate to receive the social
change leadership award which about
12 to 15 people get when they're
graduating for work on campus related to
social entrepreneurship and there's also
full-time fellowship opportunities
post-graduation
and so a couple of my friends have
received those fellowships that
pay them true full-time you know
post-business school salaries
to run their own um socially impactful
businesses post-grad
and so a plethora of opportunities for
sure
great khalil thank you for sharing that
and actually you brought up a really
important
point which also i saw surface in the
questions
especially considering some folks are
going to be coming from education
non-profit thinking about business
school and knowing that you may be
returning to a non-profit space and you
may not be joining
jp morgan right after graduation uh
certainly financing the nba
is on a lot of people's minds and i
think you mentioned that through the the
social innovation
uh center there are actually
opportunities for
for funding and support both at the
internship level
uh and uh post grad you know as
uh as an alum uh one thing i just want
to mention to the group
um because i know not everyone is is
going into non-profit here on this panel
but we also have a very generous loan
forgiveness program
so i certainly encourage you to check
out our website to learn more there so
if you are planning to go back into the
nonprofit space
there is a loan forgiveness program
through stanford because we really do
believe that we want people to pursue
their passions and pursue the careers
that they want
not just the ones they think they have
to take we don't want anyone to make any
compromises or sacrifices there so just
wanted to
add that point khalil thank you all
right question from
sri here how accessible or approachable
are professors and what is the class
dynamic like is it more collaborative
or more competitive so maybe we can
popcorn and one or two of you can take
the professor question and another can
tackle
the community front
let's tackle the community oh mackenzie
you're currently in class so you can
go ahead sure yeah i would i was also
going to tackle the community
um definitely i would say not
competitive very
um collaborative um i think in the
first quarter i was actually kind of
surprised at how many like individual
projects i had to do i had assumed it
was like
this was all group work but there was a
lot of individual work
and then like basically from the winter
quarter on it's just been like a lot of
group projects and
everybody's like very willing to pitch
in and you know things happen and things
come up and people are just like always
helping each other and
um very very very collaborative not
at all competitive um so that has been a
big plus
i would say i have heard amazing things
about professors and being able to
connect with them i think that was a big
downside of the pandemic is that
our class just didn't get to really
interact with professors i just
only ever met them over zoom and so that
has been a big bummer for us and i have
not yet had that experience but i hope
to
next year but hopefully the others can
answer that one
yeah the professors are awesome honestly
we
most of our classes we had small group
dinners
either hosted by one of the students or
the professors
themselves at their homes at our homes
so it was a very friendly environment
most of the professors
don't need to teach have been very
successful in their businesses
are there because they truly want to get
to know the students
are and are inspired by the community
that is there and they want to build
these communities communities and these
connections so
definitely highly suggest always
building a friendship with them because
they are there for that as well they're
not there
most of them are not there just to do
research or for like
other purposes they're mostly
practitioners and
want to meet awesome gs viewers
yeah i'll just a a plus 1 000 to that i
think if there's
one thing that i would encourage all gs
beers do more of it's
just attend office hours get to know the
professors they're
absolutely amazing so many of the
opportunities that i've received post
gsb or even during the gsb
um came through those relationships uh
and don't be afraid to
ask them for you know connections to
their network or to help you think
through something like they really are
there for you
um on the academic side just really
quickly there i don't know if you all
know about this
stanford has a great non-disclosure
policy uh and so
i think that helps a lot to you know
have it be a little bit more of a
collaborative environment or
i don't even know if it's collaborative
versus competitive or ver if the
what the what the right like axes are
but it's like
academic stress um is not that it's not
not
it's not in it it exists but it's um i
think especially after your first
quarter
it's v it's almost impossible to flunk
out of the gsb unless you truly
don't do anything you're go you're going
to be fine
um and so yeah that great non-disclosure
policy is
is awesome and i took advantage of it
yeah uh quick point to add in terms of
that great non-disclosure like you said
it takes some of that pressure off
and kind of drives down competition that
might exist otherwise
um i think also important to just throw
out here to everyone especially for
those of you who are concerned about
those first quarter classes and and the
quant work uh
you will have a designated academic
advisor that you will work with
um during your first year they're still
around in your second year if you want
to take advantage and they will work
with you every step of the way as you
are navigating
those course choices and the like
all right so we've talked a bit about
academics keeping an eye on the time
we were able to share some favorite
memories about favorite academic and
classroom experiences i'm wondering if
folks want to jump in with maybe some of
your favorite
uh clubs or i know dima you mentioned
you know the
arbuckle leadership fellow program were
there other programs like that or clubs
you know that were really memorable and
impactful for you personally during your
time in the program
it have to be a club or can it be an
experience in general
i think it can be an experience um
for me i know that was post covered
where we're a lucky class
but the travels were absolutely
phenomenal
every single person from the us or
non-us
would love to take people to their
cities to their countries
and i thought for me i'm in love in
learning about different cultures
i got i organized a trip for 80
classmates
who came to beirut and that for me was
the most
fulfilling thing that i did throughout
the gsb because
it sort of completed my experience i
felt like the friends i made
in class now know a side of me that they
couldn't have known
if they didn't visit my hometown and
most of them had never been here
so any cultural experience for me
at the gsb or while traveling with other
classmates was definitely the most
memorable
thing
mackenzie we certainly hope you will
have that opportunity next year
uh yvonne yeah i was going to say that
one of the memorable experiences for me
was speaking of nondisclosure there's a
writing publication for the gsb called
nondisclosure and
you get to meet the other people in the
community who love writing
and they share about their experiences
at the school they share about
experiences beyond the gsb what brought
them to the gsb
um their thoughts on current affairs so
you get to learn how your classmates are
thinking
how what they're feeling and develop
meaningful connections with your
classmates while doing so
thank you all right well i'm mackenzie
yeah um i can point to two that have
been really important to me this year
one is talk um i
haven't yet given one but um hope to
next year but that is
um one night every week a classmate will
prepare like a 30 minute kind of story
about their life and
um this year everything has been virtual
so it's been on zoom but it's actually
been amazing and
um it's like by far the most
consistently attended event
i don't think i missed a single one all
year and um and so
it's it's like truly incredible to hear
your classmates life story and to hear
kind of what they've been through and
you've got classmates literally from
all over the world and with like so many
different experiences and backgrounds
and
and people get very vulnerable and um
it's just
it's truly incredible and so that has
been an amazing
um opportunity to hear their stories and
just to be part of that and so i always
look forward to
talk nights and then the other one uh is
whim groups so this is the women in
management program
um and that is something that you can
join
um starting your winter quarter and it
doesn't have to be just
women but it's a small group of uh like
eight people
um and they pair you with a real
facilitator like a real life coach kind
of person
um and you meet every other week with
your wim group
um and you just talk about all sorts of
kind of things on your mind and
you know setting you know your values
and life goals and
i mean like we've run the gamut on
different topics and
um my group has been incredible and like
a really important source of just like
female friendships and girls and um
girls that i didn't kind of know
otherwise and so this is like a yet
another kind of circle and very
important and
again we get like very vulnerable in
those sessions and um
it's just been so important and to have
the facilitator
kind of be able to walk your group
through that has been um amazing and so
that's
something that again stanford will pay
for and it's just like a really really
cool
um part of the experience and for any
women applying i would highly recommend
that you join the work
great khalil why don't you close us out
with
your memory and then i'll do some some
final comments before we wrap up today
i would love to hear some favorite
reflections from you
reflections on classes clubs travel just
all of it yeah just if you if you think
back
you know are there any of those moments
that are tattooed on your mind
yeah i mean mackenzie you mentioned talk
which you
reminded me of it i hadn't thought about
talk in a little while
um but yeah giving my talk in the
process of writing my talk was
um yeah one certainly one of the most
memorable experiences and
uh i think changed me in pretty
interesting ways and i did mine over
zoom as well it was kind of early early
covet days
um and so that was that um
uh dima talked about travel a little bit
for
more kind of uh maybe casual or
fun travel um there's also travel or
like global experience requirements as
part of the gsb
uh and so for my gst global study trip
um we went to new zealand uh and learned
all about
kind of their agricultural industry and
dairy industry
um and it was a great chance to uh to
meet
different people that we all opted into
this trip but we didn't necessarily have
like
shared professional interests and so on
that trip i got really close to people
that i might not have necessarily gotten
close to otherwise
and i think that's one of the amazing
things that the g that the gsb does is
it kind of you get to you almost get
repotted in all of these different
places and
and build a great community around
around all those different types of
experience that you have
um and so that was really fun from like
you know watching sheep herders together
in the middle of nowhere
uh new zealand to like hanging out in
downtown auckland and
um sharing meals together and uh yeah i
made some of my best friends on that
trip actually
fantastic well thank you all for taking
some time today
to share your experiences share your
memory
i'm going to share one last thing with
the group today and that is to direct
all of you to continue your research
continue to learn more about stanford by
visiting mystanford.mba
you can actually customize this page so
you can get alerts about
upcoming events that you might be
interested stay up to date on things
that are happening
around the stanford community and
speaking of community
thank you so much to our students and
alums today for showing
this group the strength of our community
dima thank you for staying up in the
middle of the night for us
uh showing your dedication to the gsb
that means a lot to us
uh and i do hope that everyone found
this helpful today hopefully we
will answer your questions and if we
weren't you can reach out to our office
and we'll certainly do our best to get
those answered later uh and again check
out our website
feel free to join us for as many other
events you might be interested in this
summer
and just join me in thanking our uh
wonderful panel again for joining us
today thank you
so wonderful to hear your stories thank
you for sharing your time today
good night and good morning to you all